[MUSIC]
My name is Ryouta,
I am sharing this session.
And it's my great pleasure
to introduce Zoubin.
Zoubin doesn't need
an introduction, but
let me cover the basics.
Zoubin completed his PhD 90,
95, at MIT with Mike Jordan.
After that, he moved to Toronto
to do postdoc with Jeff Hinton.
Afterwards, he has been
a founding member of
Gatsby Computational
Neuroscience Unit
from 98 to 2005, and afterwards,
he has been professor at
Cambridge University here at
the Engineering Department.
He has been also
the founding Board member of
the Allen Theory Institute and
most recently has been
the chief scientist at UBA.
So I'm very excited to hear
about the latest exciting
research happening at
both the university and
at UBA on probabilistic
machine learning and AI.
>> Thanks.
Thanks, Ryouta.
Can you hear me?
It's up.
It's on.
Yeah, great.
It's really exciting to be here.
This is the second
talk I'm giving today.
The first one was at
8:30 in the morning and
it was being translated
into Mandarin.
So every time I said something
I had to wait for somebody to
translate and it made it very
difficult to give a lively talk,
especially because it
was 8:30 in the morning.
I've had a few coffees now,
so I'm much more awake.
It's a really exciting time to
be working in Machine Learning.
There's just so much going on.
The field is exploding,
it's crazy.
I never imagined that it would
be like this 20 years ago or
so, and I was starting to
get interested in this.
And it's been really, really
exciting because there's so
many applications.
20 or 30 years ago there were
a lot of people interesting
in machine learning.
We were interested in
getting AI systems working.
We wanted to get computers
to learn from data.
But it was all kind
of an academic thing.
It really didn't seem like it
was anywhere close to being
useful.
People developed algorithms just
out of scientific curiosity and
test them out on
small toy problems,
on small computers and so on.
And boy have things change,
I mean they're just
dramatically different now.
We have just to put,
just six examples that I
could fit on one slide.
We can put many, many more.
We have speech
language technologies
like speech recognition,
machine translation,
question and answering, and
dialogue systems that are really
impacting people's lives.
We have computer vision systems
that are doing things that
we really didn't
imagine were possible.
Like for example,
this famous example from
Stanford of an image
captioning system,
where, for example,
we're the same age.
That the computer has never
seen before, it produces
a caption which says [INAUDIBLE]
black shirt is playing guitar.
And that just seems
like magic for
computer vision systems
of just a decade ago.
We have machine learning that's
really impacting the sciences in
terms of areas like bio
informatics, astronomy, a lot
of sciences that are becoming
very, very data intensive.
We have of course
the systems that we've grown
very accustomed to in terms
of recommender systems
being all driven by machine
learning technologies.
A self-driving car is something
that I've become much more
involved in recently.
Really look like they're
not far from a reality
that could affect millions
of people around the world.
And just as the sixth example,
even the world of finance which
has for many years been
resistent to machine learning
Is now seeing a huge
number of start-ups and
disruption by people trying to
use machine learning methods.
So there have been these
tremendous advances, and
some the most popular ones
are these great examples
from our colleagues down
in London, DeepMind.
This was obviously a
breakthrough I'm sure all of you
know about that really launched
DeepMInd as a start up, and
caught the interest of Google
among others companies.
Where they managed to get
a machine learning system,
that combined reinforcement
learning with some deep
learning to actually perform
at Atari Games, about half
of the Atari Games it could
play at super human levels.
Which is really pretty exciting,
and
people didn't think that
that was gonna be that easy.
Then, they moved on to Go,
where now,
they've actually managed to
beat the world champion at Go.
Another kind of landmark
achievement for
AI and machine learning, again,
using heavily ideas from
reinforcement learning and
some deep learning.
And how many people know
what this is an example of?
Have you seen this?
Do you know what this is?
Raise your hand, yeah?
It's poker, so this was
another landmark achievement.
Maybe, it didn't
get as much press.
But I think it should have
gotten as much press.
From just a few months ago, this
is Libratus system developed at
Carnegie Mellon University.
Libratus is a computer.
This is how much it's winning.
And brains are a bunch of
human expert poker players and
this is how much they are losing
against the computer.
The humans are not
too happy here.
The computer really wiped
out the human experts.
And poker is really interesting
because unlike Atari and
Go, the state is very
hidden in poker.
And most of us would think of
poker as a psychological game
that involves not just
incomplete information, but
bluffing is essential to poker.
So you can't be a good poker
player unless you're good at
deceiving people.
And so this was quite an
interesting landmark achievement
recently.
And there was a team from
Alberta that also similarly had
a breakthrough in poker, just
a little bit after this one.
So for people coming into
the field of machine learning,
it seems to be a big
complicated mess.
There's so many different
methods, and the methods
are sort of rediscovered
by many different fields.
And there's sort of these
relationships between
the methods that are not
necessarily clear to people.
And I think it's useful to
spend some time trying to
organize the world of machine
learning and think about, well,
fundamentally, what's going on?
How are these methods
related to each other?
And in my world view,
everything is just
examples of some fairly
simple concepts.
What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
spend just a little bit of time
focusing on neural networks and
deep learning.
Just because it
has been really so
revolutionary in
the last few years.
But I'm also gonna spend a lot
of my time talking about my
passion, which is probabilistic
modeling and Bayesian methods.
Because again,
I feel like there is
at least the revolution
in the making there.
And it's not incompatible
with what we've done in
neural networks and
deep learning.
Any questions?
We can hopefully take some
questions at the end.
But if you wanna interrupt me,
feel free to interrupt as well.
So let's talk a little bit about
neural nets and deep learning,
because as I said,
they have been so revolutionary.
The interesting thing is
that as probably many of
you know, it's not the first
time that neural nets have
captured people's attention.
Neural nets were actually,
back in the 1980s, when
I was a teenager, that's what
really got me excited about AI.
Neural nets were going through
a big wave of excitement
in the middle to late 80s.
When I was an undergraduate and
that wave of excitement kinda
died down and is come back up.
So what are neural nets?
Just to clarify, what we mean,
they're many different
kinds of neural net.
But the main kind of neural
network that people work with
right now in the deep learning
community are essentially
tunable, nonlinear function
approximators, okay?
So a neural net is tunable,
nonlinear functions with many
parameters, but we could
call these parameters theta.
I like to use
the symbol theta for
parameters cuz that's often
what's done in statistics.
In a neural net, that would be
the weights in your neural net.
And generally, neural nets model
some input-output relationship.
That's what I mean by
the nonlinear function.
In this case, maybe the inputs
are x and the outputs are y.
And interestingly, neural nets
tend to be nonlinear, both
in terms of the parameters theta
and in terms of the inputs x.
The simplest kind of neural
net is a very old idea.
This is the equation for
logistic regression
That's basically a neural
net that takes some inputs,
does some linear projection
of those inputs, and
then maps that into
a nonlinearity that turns into
a probability of a class
being one or zero.
For example, if you're doing
classification between, I don't
know, images of cats versus
dogs or something like that.
So that's the simplest
neural net I could think of.
And if you think of
most neural networks,
essentially, what they are,
are concatenations of these
sorts of simple,
primitive operations.
So a multi-layer neural net,
this one only has one layer.
A multi-layer neural net
models the overall function,
from x to y as
a composition of functions,
each of those are the layers
in the network.
And here is an example of
a two layer version of that,
which might correspond to the
network that looks like this.
The first layer might have
elements that look like this.
And then you might linerally
combine them in a second layer
to produce the outputs, okay?
In this case, maybe with some
Gaussian noise, in this case,
for classification.
The details don't matter,
you can mix and
match these various
forms of neural net.
So these are nonlinear
tunable functions,
well what do you do with them?
How do you train them?
Generally, almost all
training algorithms for
neural networks can be seen
as maximizing a likelihood.
The likelihood is the
probability of the outputs given
the inputs, or maybe a penalized
likelihood if you're
trying to avoid over-fitting.
Using some variation on
stochastic gradient descent
optimization.
Maximizing likelihoods is an
idea that's about 100 years old
in statistics.
Gradient descent methods
are probably one of
the simplest forms
of optimization.
And so
boiled down to it's essence,
a neutral network is simply a
nonlinear function approximated
combined with a little bit
of very basic statistics and
a little bit of very
basic optimization.
The interesting thing is that
a lot of statisticians are very
confused about what
neural nets are.
I've had statisticians
come up to me and say, so
what's deep learning,
what's neural nets?
And then I explain this to them,
and they say, is that it?
And then they're like, well,
then I'm not interested, and
they sort of move on.
Whereas, we kind of know in
machine learning that even
though these are incredibly
simple, boring things,
if you throw enough
data at them,
they'll do really
interesting stuff, okay?
So that's what they are,
and what's been happening?
What is different between,
say the late 80s
when I was playing on
using neural nets for
parsing natural language and
now?
Well, there are a whole bunch
of things that are different.
So one of them is the major
rebranding exercise, and I
applaud the people who manage to
pull this off against all odds.
So now we call it deep learning.
Cuz people though neural
networks were kind of old and
passe, but deep learning sounded
like something new and deep.
And so the rebranding
exercise worked really well.
But there are a whole bunch of
new ideas as well that were
developed.
Some innovations in terms of
architectures, in particular,
going deeper, using more layers.
Using different activation
functions instead of sigmoid,
rectified linears.
New ways of regularizing them
with things like drop out.
Rediscoveries of some old and
kind of interesting ideas like
LSTMs for time series, etc.
So there were some innovations,
and the rate of innovation
just keeps going.
But importantly,
there are just vastly
larger data sets right now.
Really web-scale data that you
can throw at these things.
And along with that, we have
vastly larger compute resources.
We can actually run stuff
on the cloud, with GPUs.
People now talk about like
hundreds of cores on a single
experiment and things like that,
that were unimaginable
a couple of decades ago.
We also have much
better software tools,
things that have really managed
to democratize people's
ability to run neural networks
and reproduce experiments.
To the extent that you could be
a high school student with good
programming skills and
not really even understand
what a derivative is.
And you can reproduce somebody's
blog post on neural nets, and
think, wow, cool, I'm doing AI. Right?
And that's really what's
transformed the inflow of
excitement and interest.
That's also translated into
vastly increased industry
investment, just because
these systems have started to
produce exciting results.
And along with that,
there's been massive media hype.
Okay, and the media hype,
the many ways of explaining it.
One of them is when companies
start spending hundreds of
millions of dollars
on something,
the media pays attention.
If it looks like it has
something to do with
the brain and Terminator and
stuff like that,
then the media go totally crazy.
And you can imagine all the
stories that come out of that.
Of course it feeds on itself,
and then the next company
comes along and says,
no, we're missing out.
We need to spend a few hundred
million on this as well, right?
Okay so, this is what's happened
since the 80s and 90s, and
it really has been a revolution.
I wanna be grounded in reality,
but I don't wanna minimize
from the fact that it has
had a major, major impact.
But it's important not to
get caught up in the fantasy
that AI is solved, or
something like that.
If you actually look at
these nonlinear function
approximators, they have
a lot of limitations.
And here are a few of
their limitations.
So, one of them is that neural
nets tend to be, by and
large, very very data hungry.
Humans are pretty good at
learning from a few examples.
And neural nets, in most cases,
need large numbers of examples,
sometimes millions of examples.
They're are also extremely
compute-intensive.
So if you think about, again,
to use our poor primate brains
as an example, we operate
with the power consumption
of a light bulb basically.
And if you look at
a cloud full of GPUs or
something, that's using
massive amounts of energy and
compute to solve fairly
simple problems.
Neural nets and deep learning
systems are actually quite poor
at representing uncertainty.
And this is something that
really bothers me, and
I'll talk about in
some detail very soon.
They're also easily fooled
by adversarial examples.
So, how many people have seen,
here,
adversarial examples
in neural nets.
Raise your hand if
you've seen them.
Raise your hand if you
haven't seen them.
Okay.
I need to account for
the fact that some people just
don't like raising their hands.
You always have to
ask both questions.
So as you've seen, adversarial
examples are examples that
are either perceptually
indistinguishable
from another example, but
that give the neural network
a wildly different output, or
that the examples are wildly
different from anything
that you've seen.
And the neural network is
confidentially giving you some
output, some response for that.
So again, it has something
to do with the neural net's
inability to represent
uncertainty.
Neural nets are finicky
to optimize.
It's actually quite hard
to do the optimization.
They're generally
uninterpretable black-boxes.
They lack in transparency, and
they're difficult to trust.
And actually, when you look at
examples, an industry where
things get deployed, if you're
just doing something fairly
harmless, maybe you're just
classifying images for fun,
then it's okay to be wrong and
not know why you're wrong.
But if you're doing something
actually rather important,
like detecting pedestrians or
something like that in a
self-driving car, then the fact
that you have a non-transparent
black-box system that you
can't then easily debug, becomes
potentially a non-starter.
You can't even think of using
that, unless you have some
reasonable guarantees, and some
reasonable ways of understanding
what it's doing and
debugging it.
So these are some
of the limitations.
And what I wanna do is, I want
to actually talk a little bit
about going beyond
deep learning.
And of course I have my
own particular bias.
There are many ways to
go beyond deep learning.
And in fact, to be fair,
many people realize all
of these limitations.
And if you talked to some of the
best research labs in the world,
they're working on various
aspects of trying to solve these
things.
But one way of thinking about
going beyond deep learning is to
take maybe a slightly
different approach.
To machine learning.
So, a lot of people when they
learn about machine learning,
they take a course.
And the course basically-
I've looked at a lot of these
syllabuses around the world,
and the syllabus usually looks
like- sorry,
I found the back of this.
It just looks like
a toolkit of methods.
So you'll learn about this,
you'll learn about random
forest, then you'll
learn k-means,
then you'll learn about back
propagation, then you'll learn
about Q-learning, and
it's just a bag of stuff, right?
There a little bit of an attempt
at making some theory
connections, like
you probably want to
have some theoretical analysis
of empirical performance,
like generalization error and so
on of various different methods.
The framework that I'm
gonna talk about which
I'm quite in love with, although
it has its own limitations,
is thinking about machine
learning as kind of a science
of learning models from data.
And so most things can be
put under that rubric,
not everything.
But the idea is that there is
sort of like an overarching
scientific framework for
doing machine learning, and
the details of the algorithms
are just that, they are details.
They matter, but you kinda
look at the bigger picture and
the bigger framework.
So what do I mean by
learning from data and
what do I mean by modeling,
in particular?
So here is this sort of
view of machine learning as
probabilistic modelling.
Well, let's step back and
ask ourselves what is a model?
Okay, the term model is use in
many, many different fields,
it means different things
to different people.
>> But one way of
thinking about models is,
a model is a description
of possible data you could
observe from a system, okay?
>> So the way you tell, it might
also be an understandable,
interpretable or
something like that,
like a model in the sciences or
something like that, or
an economic model, or
model in biology, and so on.
All of these,
the term model gets used a lot,
but I think ultimately
if the model can't make some
claims about potential data,
then it's very hard to know
if it's a good model or not.
At some point, you have to
ground the model in data, and
not the data that you had before
because very easy to say,
my model fits my
old data perfectly.
The model should say
something about data you
haven't observed yet.
Now because of that,
modeling is intimately tied to
the concept of uncertainty.
So to make any claims about
data we haven't observed yet,
we have to be honest about our
uncertainty in terms of the data
we haven't observed yet.
You can't have, for example,
a weather forecasting model that
gives you a precise temperature
for tomorrow without tell you
what it's uncertainty is,
it just doesn't make much sense.
So we're gonna use
the mathematics of probability
theory to express all
forms of uncertainty and
noise associated with our model.
And then, it turns out that,
that same mathematical framework
can be used to do inferences
about unknown quantities, adapt
our models, make predictions,
and learn from data.
And all of this used to
be called probability.
This part used to maybe
sometimes we called inverse
probability until early
in the 20th century when
Fisher, who's a classical,
sort of one of the founders
of classical statistics said,
that probability,
that inverse probability,
you're just followers of
Thomas Bayes, you're Bayesians.
And he coined, actually he
coined the term Bayesian as
a derogatory term to distinguish
himself because he was
creating a new view
on statistics.
So we can call it inverse
probability if we wanna go back
in time, and the framework
basically boils down to a very,
very simple set of concepts.
So in the world of probabilistic
modeling and Bayesian machine
learning and so on, there
are only two kinds of things.
There are stuff you observe or
measure,
that's what you call data, and
then there's everything else.
Everything else is stuff
that you didn't measure.
So necessarily,
you have to be uncertain about
the stuff you didn't measure.
And we're going to use
the mathematics of probability
theory to represent all
forms of uncertainty.
Just like we use calculus to
represent rates of change,
probability theory is
the mathematics of uncertainly.
And actually don't like
the term randomness
because it connotes
something weird.
Actually, I don't
believe much is random.
For example, I can be uncertain
about how many people are in
this room, right?
I'm certainly uncertain
about that, but
the number of people in this
room is not random in a usual
colloquial sense of the word.
And when I look at this room,
that's data that my brain gets
about the number of people here.
My brain is trying
to process that.
And I'm guessing maybe there
are between, I don't know,
40 and 90 people in this room.
Probably more than 40, I don't
know, maybe between 50 and 90.
All right, so how do I
represent that uncertainty?
Well, the idea in
probabilistic modeling is use
probability distributions for
all forms of uncertainty, okay?
So you use probability
distributions for uncertainty.
You get data, for
example, I'm looking.
And I might collect more data,
let's say I start counting.
That's just
collecting more data.
And at some point,
my uncertainty collapses.
Learning is the process
of going from a state
of knowledge before observing
the data, that's the prior,
to a state of knowledge
after observing the data.
And the process by which you go
through that is a very simple
process.
You take your prior, which is
the distribution over your
uncertain quantities,
your hypotheses.
You multiply it by
the likelihood,
which is a probability
of the observed data for
any one of your hypotheses.
Like the number of people
in the room would be
various hypotheses
I could entertain.
You multiply the prior
by the likelihood.
You renormalized summing over
all the hypotheses you're
willing to consider.
And then you get the posterior
distribution over hypotheses
given data.
It's as straightforward as that.
And the beauty of this is
that we can use this as
a unifying principle for
a lot of machine learning.
Not necessarily for the parts
of machine learning that involve
decision-making, like
reinforcement learning.
That involves an additional
thing that we need to add on top
of this Bayesian framework.
But for most of the rest
of machine learning,
we can actually use this to
understand what's going on.
So it turns out actually
Bayes' rule isn't even
a fundamental rule.
Bayes' rule is a corollary of
two even-simpler rules from
probability theory, the sum
rule and the product rule.
And here are the sum rule and
the product rule written
out in a boring form,
as you might find in a textbook.
Sum rule says that the
probability of some variable is
the sum or integral if that
other variable is continuous
over some other variable y
of the joint probability.
And the product rule says that
the joint probability of two
variables, x and y, can be
factored into this marginal
probability of x times
the conditional probability
of y given x, or
the other way around.
The basic rules you might
learn about in a textbook.
If we take these x's and y's,
and we replace them by things
that we might actually
might be interested in.
Like D for data, theta for
parameters of a model.
And then condition everything on
m, which may be like the model
class like what we
are currently considering.
Then we get a single equation,
this is now Bayes' rule,
that defines learning
from data for parameters.
And it says, well, you have
a model with some parameters.
Before observing the data,
you have a prior.
Which represents your
uncertainty about
what those parameters could be.
Then you observe the data, so
you multiply the prior
by this likelihood term.
And then you renormalize it with
this interesting quantity called
the marginal likelihood.
And that gives you the posterior
over parameters given the data.
It's very straightforward.
If you had to make predictions,
then probability theory tells
you that to predict any unknown
quantity, call that unknown
quantity x, given the data
that you've observed.
Then the sum and product rule
tell you there's only one and
only one way of
doing prediction.
And that is average or
integrate the predictions for
different parameter values
weighted by this posterior
probability over parameter
values that you've considered in
the equation above.
So prediction in the Bayesian
framework is naturally
an ensembling process
where you're averaging, or
voting together,
many different predictors.
And model comparison is
essentially just the application
of Bayes rule at a level
suddenly higher up
from parameters to
a level of models.
Like, for example, are there,
I don't know, three or four
clusters in the data or should
I have 10 or 20 hidden units?
These are all modeling
questions, right, and
you could answer them in
principle using this framework.
So any questions about that?
[BLANK AUDIO]
>> Can you be more specific with
why the enforcement learning
doesn't fit into this framework?
>> So
the framework I've talked about
talks about inference from data.
Think about that as
knowledge acquisition or
learning from data.
Reinforcement learning
falls into decision theory.
So actually,
it's not incompatible,
it's just that it's a part.
So there's Bayesian
inference and
there's Bayesian
decision theory.
Bayesian decision theory says
one side inferred everything I'm
interested in.
Now maybe there is a loss
function which tells me what
the loss is for various
different states of the world.
And I should take actions that
minimize my expected loss, and
that's reinforcement learning.
Loss, reward,
it's the same thing.
It's not immediate reward,
you're looking at
long-term reward.
So it's Bayesian sequential
decision theory would be how we
would think about any sequential
decision problem as in
reinforcement learning,
and it's nothing new.
Been around for
60 years at least, yeah.
>> I've got a question about
the learning behaviors.
So what we're trying to
learn is the posterior of
the parameters given
some observed data?
>> Yes.
>> Is it assumed that the other
quantities in that equation
are all given beforehand, so
the likelihood of
the parameters in
the model m is something
that we're given?
>> So usually, this term here,
the likelihood is something
that we assume is known.
But the funny thing
is that actually,
we shouldn't really necessarily
assume that the likelihood
function is even known.
Maybe the likelihood function
has some parameters, but
you have to infer.
But if you consider a family
of likelihood functions,
you can just say that they're
just extra parameters you have
to infer from data that allow
you to choose between different
likelihood functions.
It gets a little bit subtle.
But just like in, basically,
in almost all of statistics and
also machine learning, people
assume that the likelihood or
the loss function is
given to you, and
then they try to optimize it.
But I actually think your
question is really insightful,
because in most of those cases,
that's the weak
point in the model.
That thing was an assumption.
Everything is an assumption.
The only thing that's not
an assumption is the data.
Everything else
is an assumption.
And so
from the Bayesian point of view,
what we really should be doing
is questioning every assumption,
and not just questioning
the assumptions, but
actually doing
something about that.
Trying to improve on
those assumptions.
So loss functions and
likelihoods are also
assumptions.
Let me move on, so why should we
care about this whole framework?
I mean,
deep learning has been so
spectacularly successful
that you would think, well,
we can forget about all
this probability theory and
just run whatever Adam on
my tensor flow model, and
I'll be fine, or whatever.
Well, here's at least one
of the reasons I care, or
two of the reasons I care,
actually.
So one of them is we
really want, I think,
we really want calibrated
models, where the prediction
uncertainties are something
we can believe in.
And it's not just
kind of a nice thing.
I think it's actually
a necessary thing.
We really need machine learning
systems that know when they
don't know.
That if they're
given a new input,
they'll tell you,
I don't know what the answer is.
We don't want them to be
confidently making stupid
mistakes.
If they're confidently
making stupid mistakes,
they'll be fine in the lab.
They'll never get deployed
in the real world.
The other thing is that this
framework actually gives
us a really nice way of doing
automatic model control and
structure learning.
So learning the structure of
models automatically from data.
And that's really beautiful,
because of the things that
annoys me the most about current
machine learning practice is
that people just come up
with stuff out of thin air.
Right, and it's just like
a cottage industry of people
randomly inventing stuff,
testing it out a couple of
times, and then saying, this
works better than other things.
It's just not a systematic
science, it's a hodgepodge.
It's really disappointing.
And we would like to make
it a systematic science.
And actually, the way to make
it a systematic science is get
the human out of the loop.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I mean, maybe,
make the human do other things
or kind of oversee things.
But the search over models
should be something that's
done by a computer
systematically.
And this framework gives us
a nice way of doing that.
So just to be concrete about
what does it mean to be
Bayesian, here it is in
the context of a neural network.
So in the context of
a neural network,
what are the sources
of uncertainty?
Well, the parameters
are uncertain, right?
Cuz you don't know what
the parameters are.
And actually,
the structure is uncertain.
People haven't really dealt
with structure uncertainty.
But in an ideal world, I would
love to see both parameter and
structure uncertainty dealt
with in a neural network.
It just might not
be very practical.
But that's why I said
in an ideal world.
And actually, their sorta
world of neural networks and
deep learning, and the world
of Bayesian machine learning
are not in any sorta conflict.
They are actually
quite compatible.
The two kinda live
in different spaces.
So neural networks
are a kind of model,
some kind of function
approximator.
And Bayesian methods
are just a framework for
thinking about learning.
So people, for a couple of
decades at least, have thought
about applying Bayesian
methods to neural networks.
And so here are some examples
going back to the early 90s.
People like David MacKay,
Radford Neal,
Geoff Hinton worked on this.
Even Yann LeCun worked on this,
even earlier,
even though he didn't
realize he was doing this.
He will admit to that.
He was sort of analyzed from
a physics-y perspective, but
it turned out, he was doing
Bayes' rule on neural network
rates in the late 80s.
Who's sitting here has
really nice paper on
Stochastic Gradient
Langevin Dynamics.
It's a real beautiful idea where
you can take stochastic gradient
descent, SGD, add noise to
it in a particular way and
show that it approximates
actually doing Bayesian Learning
in neural network parameters.
And some of our work in
the machine learning group in
Cambridge has also been
kindadeveloping better ways of
doing Bayesian neural networks,
Bayesian deep learning.
We had a workshop at NIPS,
which was great fun last year.
We are trying to have
another one this year.
And here is an example
of why we might care.
If you have some data and
you're fitting a neural network
to some input-output data,
where you have data,
you can afford to be confident.
But where you don't have data,
what you really want is
something that shows a great
deal of uncertainty.
So that's sort of the ideal
thing that we want.
So when do we need
probabilities?
Just to kind of summarize some
of the threads of thinking I've
described.
I think we need probabilities
when we want to really carefully
represent uncertainty.
So this includes things like
forecasting, decision making.
Usually, decisions are made on
the basis of future consequences
of actions.
So we need to have
a representation of
the consequences of our actions
when we're learning from
limited, noisy, or missing data.
For example, in medical domains,
this is very, very useful.
Or if we're doing complex
personalized modelling like in
advertising, or
again, in medicine.
All data compression methods are
basically probabilistic models,
either implicitly or explicitly.
And for automating this sort
of scientific approach to
modelling, this is quite useful.
So now, as mentioned,
I'm sort of leading Uber's AI
research right now.
And so why would a company like
Uber care about something like
probabilistic modeling?
Well, it turns out
that actually,
it's everywhere that we look.
So in the research lab that
I'm trying to build at Uber,
we have people with deep
learning expertise.
We have people with
reinforcement learning and
probabilistic modeling
expertise, and so on.
They're a bunch of different
communities in there.
But when we look around,
there are actually a huge number
of very Clear probabilistic
modelling problems.
So if you look at the kinds of
data, the kinds of modelling
that we have to do to optimize
the service that we provide,
this involves understanding
the spatial temporal dynamics in
being able to forecast that for
both drivers which is the supply
and riders which is
the demand side.
We have to be able to model ETA,
how long it takes for
food or person or
package to get from A to B,
we use models in all of our
forecasting and planning.
We're modeling cities,
we're modeling traffic.
It's all about modeling stuff.
And these are complicated
systems to model.
And so we can use combinations
of deep learning and
sort of function approximators,
and probabilistic modeling to
build sophisticated
forecasting models and
then to optimize
the system on top of that.
So the service is just
better for everybody.
And that is, I said all of that
and I'm not even talking about
self-driving cars which is
a whole, now there are several
hundred people working on
self-driving cars at Uber.
And there are many modeling
problems as well in that domain.
And of course, we're also try to
build personal aviation service
which I'm sure will come
with this modeling problem.
This is by 2020 we have
committed to doing trials in
Dubai and Dallas of what you and
I would all call flying cars.
But the guys who run that at
Uber hate the term flying cars.
Cuz they don't actually drive on
the road, they're sort of like
giant drones that you get
into and you fly from A to B.
So watch out In
the next few years, but
this is part of what
we're also trying to do.
And again, although initially
the vertical takeoff and
landing vehicles
will be piloted,
eventually these will be
autonomous electrical vehicles.
So all the same sorts of
inference perception and
modeling problems that
occur in the self driving
domain will also occur
in the flying domain.
So that's it for the uber stuff.
For the rest of the time that
I have, a few more minutes,
what I wanna do is I wanna
talk about three areas that I
think are really exciting
at the cutting edge
of machine learning and
AI right now.
And these are areas
that my group and
myself are working on,
that we're very excited about.
I've already talked a little bit
about Bayesian deep learning.
I'm not gonna talk
much more about that.
I'm basically gonna talk about
probabilistic programming,
the automatic statistician, and
Bayesian optimization,
very briefly on each of those.
So let's start with
probabilistic programming.
The idea of probabilistic
programming is all
this probabilistic modeling
stuff is nice, but
it's really time consuming to
define a probabilistic model and
then derive an inference
algorithm and
implement the inference
algorithm and so on.
And it's not just
time consuming, but
it's incredibly error prone.
The solution to that
comes in the form
of this field of
probabilistic programming.
And the idea is a two-part idea.
One of them is,
instead of defining your model
as a bunch of equations, or
something like that or
a graphical model, a diagram
in a paper, define your model
as a computer program, okay.
The computer program
that can generate data.
Now it could be a conditional
data generator,
like if you're trying to
generate y as a function of x.
The program could take an x and
produce possible ys,
that's a conditional program.
Or it could be a generative
model of like x,
like if you're trying to build a
generative model for language or
speech or something like that it
could generate the whole signal
for you.
In any case,
it's a computer program.
And that idea is obviously very
old, like we have simulators.
Many, many fields of science and
engineering have relied on
simulators, which are computer
programs for their models.
The really interesting bit
of probabilistic programming
is this second part,
which is given your model,
defined as a simulator,
we can actually define
a Universal Inference Engine,
and that is
a system that will basically do
Bayes rule on computer programs.
So what does that mean
actually in practice?
What that means is I
have a simulator for
potential data which has a bunch
of random variables in it.
But now, I have some real data,
that's the data I've
actually observed.
And what I'd like to do is
I would like to figure out,
what are the plausible hidden
variables or random variables in
my simulator that are consistent
with my real data?
If I can do that,
that's actually solving Bayes'
rule on my computer program.
Well, let's think
about it this way.
We're all used to running
computer programs in
the forward direction.
You give them inputs and
they produce outputs.
This is like
thinking about running them
in the backward direction.
Given that I know what the
outputs are, that was the data.
What are the calls for
the random number generator
that are consistent
with those outputs?
That's the basic concept.
And this sounds kind
of like magic, but
it's actually possible.
And there'd been a whole
bunch of systems here
around that have
developed on this idea.
And I wanna call out,
in particular, a system that
was developed at Microsoft
research, in particular,
in this lab here, which was
really way ahead of its time.
Over ten years ago, infer.NET
was really like the most
powerful policy programming
language for scalable modeling.
But by now,
we have a whole bunch of
different languages that have
been developed including
sharing which is a language
developed in my group and I will
show you some examples of that.
And then under the hood,
what's happening is
that we have a whole bunch
of inference algorithms.
These are methods
that can be used to
figure out what those hidden
variables are, giving the data.
And these are various forms
of Markov chain Monte Carlo,
variation inference, or
particle filter and etcetera.
Here's an example from
the programming language Turing.
Maybe what I'll do is
I'll play you the video.
It's just easier to
explain I think.
Okay, so let me just make sure.
Okay, I guess that's right.
All right, so
if you're familiar with,
how many people know what
a hidden Markov model is?
Raise your hand if you know it.
Okay, good, almost everybody.
So here is a hidden
Markov model defined
in this probabilistic
programming language, Turing.
The main things that are here
are this model construct.
Turing is based on Julia, a kind
of nice, modern scientific
programming language which
is meant to be a kind of
a replacement for MathLab and
r and everything else.
And here's an h and m defined,
and the main thing to notice is
this little tilde character
which is drawn from.
So this define as it's
drawn from the categorical
distribution, either the states
have it in Markov Model, and
these are the outputs,
like a normal, drawn from
a normal distribution.
This, I would argue,
is about as natural and
compact representation
of an HMM,
as I would imagine having
in a programming language.
So, the surface form
is really nice.
In, for instance like this, you
say I'm gonna do sampling on my
HMM, and I'm gonna use particle
GIBs with some parameters.
So this is a call to
the inference algorithm,
you don't have to
implement that.
And then what happens
is you run this.
And a few minutes later,
it actually has done inference.
This is just a visualization of
the hidden states over time,
which is a bit boring, they're
jumping around a little bit.
I'll just show another example
maybe, and then we can move on.
Okay, so here is another example
of a Hidden Markov Model,
but what this is, is it's
a Bayesian Hidden Markov Model.
Bayesian Hidden Markov Model,
by this we mean,
a Hidden Markov Model where
we're actually representing
the uncertainty in
the transition matrix and
in the parameters of
the emission model.
So we just add a couple
four extra lines to this,
to turn our previous code
into a Bayes and HMM.
And again we can do it and
solve that In this case, it's
a combination of Hamiltonian
Monte Carlo and particle gibbs,
all wrapped into an outer loop
of inference, with gibbs.
And this is just a visualization
of inference on that.
And now, it has some of
uncertainty about where
the means of the different
observations are, and
that's shown here.
Okay, and
maybe I'll show one last one.
So this is just defining
a mixture of categoricals.
Let's jump ahead.
This is defining
Latent Dirichlet allocation.
Again, the code for Latent
Dirichlet allocation is really
pretty straightforward, okay.
So it's sort of nice and
abstract that way, okay.
So that was probabilistic
programming.
Let me move on, question?
Yeah.
>> Is there any restriction
on what effects you can do?
Or are they all just MCMC,
kind of-
>> So
the restriction is on stuff
that we've implemented, okay.
And so, there are a few
algorithms we've implemented
under the hood.
My team is implementing
some other ones.
Different probabilistic
programming languages have
different things that
people have implemented.
So we've done various versions
of particle filtering,
MCMC with
Hamiltonian Monte Carlo, NUTS.
We're trying to reproduce
what Stan does, and
benchmark against that.
I mean, completely honestly,
it's a very nice framework cuz
it's all naturally
embedded in Julia.
It's not as fast as a language
like Stan because that's
actually optimized for finite
models whereas we can actually
deal with a broader
class of models.
And we're working on making it
all much more efficient and
scalable.
And this is what's going
on actually, interestingly,
I have an effort like this
going on at Cambridge.
And the Uber AI labs know
of good men who's one of
the pioneers of probalistic
programming is working at Uber
now and we're developing
a scalable kind of industry
strength probalistic programming
language at Uber as well.
>> Can you define
how scalable it is?
These frameworks not
only take time, but
are not very scalable.
>> In terms of data?
>> And in computation.
>> Yeah, I mean, the target that
we have is as scalable as deep
learning frameworks.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, so parallelizable,
run on GPUs, etc.
And in fact, we're
piggybacking on top of deep
learning kind of
frameworks that exist, and
adding a layer of probabilistic
programming to them, yeah?
>> Related to
scalability advantage,
I don't know this question
is in the right context, but
what happens if you're learning
parameters that are actually
related to each other,
being conflict with each other?
Does that then make it that
you need to learn covariance
matrices, as well, or-
>> Yeah, in theory,
if you have a model with many
parameters, in the posterior,
the parameters will
be correlated,
even if in the prior,
they're not correlated.
In practice, what people do
is either they ignore that,
which is an approximation, or
they use a sampling method
where you can infer the
correlation from the samples.
Let me move on cuz, I mean,
I've been taking some
questions along the way.
But I wanna leave at least
a couple of minutes for
questions at the end as well.
I'm gonna move on to very
quickly talk about the two other
ideas, Bayesian Optimization.
The idea of Bayesian
Optimization is that we wanna do
global optimization of some
black-box functions that
are expensive to evaluate.
So this is the basic idea,
find the arg max of f(x)
as a function of x.
Very simple idea but
the key thing is,
what if evaluating f(x)
costs quite a lot of time or
money or energy or
whatever it is?
What do you do then?
Well, the right thing to do then
is you treat this as a problem
in sequential
decision-making and
you model the uncertainty that
you have in the function f
to figure out what
the optimal actions are.
And this has just a huge
number of applications.
And it's important to think
beyond the little world of
machine learning to think about
all of the other aspects of
science and
engineering that might
involve optimizing something.
Anywhere we can
optimize something,
we can actually do a Bayesian
Optimization, I think.
If certain criteria hold.
This is just Bayesian
optimization in a nutshell.
The thing that drives it is,
you're making decisions about
where to evaluate the function.
This is the function,
let's say, you're uncertain
about the function,
that's why it's sort of shown
with the shaded region.
You've evaluated some data.
This is why you're
being Bayesian.
You're actually trying to
represent the uncertainty that
you have in your function.
And then, based on that
uncertainty, what you'll have is
something called an acquisition
function which is telling
you where it's best to
evaluate your function next.
It's sort of trading
off exploration and
exploitation cuz it's
a decision making problem.
So where is this useful?
I've already said I actually
think it's useful to think about
any optimization problem.
In particular, if evaluating
the function is expensive,
if evaluating derivatives
is hard or impossible.
If there is noise in
the function evaluations, or
there may be noisy constraints.
Or there is prior information
about the function that you
might wanna use in
optimization or
if you need to optimize
many similar functions.
So in all of these contexts
actually helps to think about
things in terms of
Bayesian optimisation.
So the last thing I wanna talk
about is very, very quickly,
this idea of
the Automatic Statistician.
And the idea here is that
we have a lot of data, but
we don't have enough
data scientists.
So what can we do?
We can super power
the data scientists or
we can replace
the data scientists.
And that's really the idea of
building systems that automate
model discovery from data.
And I see Riota standing up.
That's what happens when you
take questions in an already too
long a talk.
So no, no, no, it's fine.
We can sort of run through it.
Maybe I'll just show you the
video which only takes a couple
of minutes.
So this system basically takes
raw data in the form of a table.
It searches over good models.
It finds a good model.
And then it turns that
model into a report that
describes patterns in
the data to a human user.
And the key thing is that
this is really meant to be
the opposite of a black box.
You really want
a transparent box.
You want the computer to
explain in English what is
found in the data to you.
So here is just a demo of the
Automatic Statistician running
on a classic,
tiny data set called Iris.
So you load up the data.
And then, it turns away and
thinks about lots of
different models.
And then what
happens is you wait.
It says your report
is being prepared.
This is the report
that it prepares.
It's actually found,
it's evaluated a few
different models.
Actually, what happened there?
What happened was that
the report was actually
a dynamic object.
So it keep thinking
about models and
it keeps updating the report
which is a web page.
Now the report is sort of
finished and this is a very
basic version where it's
doing some visualizations.
What it decided was
that the best model for
explaining what's in the data
is to assume that there
are just three
clusters in the data.
Which actually, if you know
Iris, is not a bad assumption,
sort of discovered
that on its own.
And then it produces a whole
bunch of visualizations that
show you that there's hypothesis
of three clusters in the data
Okay, so, I think I'm now
basically ready to move,
jump to the conclusions.
That's just
the Automatic Statistician.
We've done it for
classification as well.
And I wanna conclude by saying a
lot of the things I've described
in this talk are in this
review paper that I'm happy,
if you can get it online,
to share with people.
And I wanted to thank a whole
bunch of collaborators
that I've had.
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]